when she's not in her Karate uniform
Tori may seem strikingly familiar she's
played by Peyton List after a couple of
early uncredited roles Peyton List made
her true acting debut in the 2008
romantic comedy 27 Dresses as the
younger version of the protagonist Jane
Nichols list starred as Emma Ross for
all four seasons of the Disney Channel
series Jesse and the spin-off show
bunked while she was still a regular on
Jesse she took a role in The Diary of a
Wimpy Kid films she plays the main
character Greg's Crush Holly Hills and
both Broderick rules and Dog Days the
second to third films of the series
after her character on bunk'd left
summer camp to become a model Liz took
on a totally different kind of teen show
Hulu's Supernatural Thriller light is a
feather any wire compared the series to
Pretty Little Liars as it also features
a group of teenage girls faced with the
death of one of their own who were then
forced to unravel the mystery list plays
the teenage clicks leader Olivia in the
first season and then returns briefly in
the second this role served as a leaping
off point for list as she then went on
to play the complicated Tori in Cobra
Kai